[Musik]
hey wer bist du denn hin zu dem gehörst
du
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit
[Musik]
du schon wieder ich kann ich nicht
mitnehmen sorry gerne wird mich
umbringen sollte doch was war das
gelände ganz kess mit dem auch sei dann
denkbar ist auch dass kate wenn ich habe
richtig gelebt und weg jedoch sinnlos
was ihr uns wird das klopapier
angezündet das ist ja meine augen
brennen was du musst du
[Musik]
dazu das war es auch schon von diesem
video ich hoffe es hat echt ultra lang
gedauert vielleicht habt ihr gesehen
dass wir dieses video schon im januar
gedreht am lehrer noch nicht zusammen an
dieser stelle schon mal danke ein leon
für die kamera und auch danke am revers
sich die zeit genommen hat und
mitgemacht hat und auch vielen dank an
den philipp der mir bei der story
geholfen hat jetzt ist endlich raus ich
hab mich schon so auf dieses video
gefreut ich freue mich auch richtig
jetzt euer feedback in den kommentaren
gleich direkt zu lesen wenn euch das
noch nicht gereicht hat und euch darauf
freuen dass ich noch ganz viele diese
folgen machen wer denn das soll eine
serie seien unfälle wurde ich habe noch
richtig viele ideen wie diese pokémon
zum leben erwecken können mit krassen
attacken kassen leuten an kassen wollten
und auch noch andere pokémon natürlich
vielleicht habt ihr ideen dann schwarz
auf jeden fall in die kommentare und
schaut auf jeden fall bei leon philipp
und rede vor bei der im links in ganz
oben in der beschreibung von sich
gefallen lassen wenn er nichts mehr
verpassen wollt und nicht auf dieser
reise begleiten möchte dann abonniert
mich doch gerne und dann sehen wir
zunächst mal wieder
[Musik]